[Musique]
en vrai il y a un truc qui me frappe
quand même
c'est tous les gens qui continuent à
m'appeler elle
ça me fera
je pense que c'est au-delà de
la gentillesse c'est juste un manque de
respect alors que je souffre comme toute
personne grouille de cette société qui
n'arrive même pas à se
questionner collectivement sur ces
violences patriarcales en fait
et en même temps tout ce que je suis en
train de faire qui est mon up grille
artistique vous vous y faites même pas
attention et vous m'appelez elle
des fois j'ai envie de vous dire vous
faire [__] en fait
[Musique]
la vie est ainsi faite que c'est jamais
simple
la parole est à notre collègue Sabine
rexeler pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]